in recent decades leftist activists have
popularized the claim that one in five
women will be raped during their
undergraduate years some radicals have
inflated that statistic to one in four
now if those numbers would true were
true it would mean that women on the
picturesque green of Harvard Yard are in
Greater danger of violent sexual attack
than they would be in the back alleys of
Botswana
no reasonable person believes that least
of all the purported victims many of
whom according to the source of that
statistic quote had not realized they
had been raped until left-wing activists
informed them of their victimhood
many people have heard the one in five
statistic very few people know where it
comes from
it comes from a 13-question survey
designed by the social scientist Mary
Koss for Kent State University students
back in 1976.
the first 12 questions addressed various
sexual acts with different degrees of
ambiguity the 13th question asked
bluntly have you ever been raped and
according to Mary Coss many respondents
got the question wrong
seems a little strange doesn't it seems
like the sort of question that a
respondent would not be able to get
wrong
but cost did not like how few women
reported having been raped so she
rewrote and re-administered the survey
to 6 000 University students across 32
campuses throughout the country she
determined that 27 percent of
respondents that's more than one in four
I'm no mathematician but I'm pretty sure
that's one more than one in four
had suffered rape since the age of 14.
but only 55 percent of those clinically
classified victims agreed with Costas
assessment now even the real number that
costs found would be troubling very
troubling if true
and we'll get to that in one second
but costs like all the other liberal
hoaxers could not help but embellish and
lie to further her political agenda
a more recent survey by the Association
of American universities arrived at the
one in four statistic in an even cruder
way
the social scientists administering the
survey simply redefined rape
the surveyors found that 11 of female
undergraduate respondents suffered rape
according to the legal definition of
those terms rape or sodomy but that
number soared to 23 percent when
measured by the vagar category of sexual
assault which might include any unwanted
quote grabbing groping or rubbing
against the other in a sexual way even
if the touching is over the other's
clothes
but the broad definition robs the
statistic of all of its meaning
one cannot compare an unwanted pinch
however unpleasant however immoral
however illegal to rape still even
discarding the Preposterous one in four
number the survey's findings that 11 11
of female undergraduates had suffered
rape or sodomy that still sounds
implausibly High
and a closer look at the data reveals
that it is because just half of those 11
percent of respondents reported any
Force involved in their encounter the
other half reported being too drunk to
give consent according to the law which
raises a problem for the statisticians
sexual encounters and drinking go hand
in hand on college campuses I do not
need to inform an audience of college
students of that fact
depending on the circumstances the law
or a social scientist with an agenda
might classify an ostensibly consensual
sexual encounter as rape even if neither
party involved agreed with that
assessment a crime might well have taken
place
one party or even both parties might
have considered the encounter coercive
even absent physical Force
the structure of the survey means we
simply cannot know
but even counting none of the drunken
encounters is raped five and a half
percent that is a staggering number
are one out of every 18 girls on college
campuses really raped during their
education that statistic would be
horrifying if it were true
it almost certainly is not true not even
close to true as even the researchers
had to admit the reason is that fewer
than one in five students who were asked
to take the survey agreed to do so
hundreds of thousands of students chose
not to participate this likely accounts
for a non-response bias
non-response bias
according to the researchers
is when students who have been assaulted
are more likely to take the survey in
the first place
these methodological issues and others
explain the discrepancy between one and
four and one and five and the data that
the department of justices have gathered
over the past several decades which show
that female college students are
significantly less likely to be raped or
sexually assaulted than non-student
women of the same age
the doj found a victimization rate of
7.6 among one thousand non-students and
6.1 among 1 000 students in both cases
the doj data show victimization rates
more than an order of magnitude lower
than the liberal ideological surveys
suggest not only is Harvard not more
dangerous for women than Botswana it
isn't even more dangerous than the
surrounding neighborhoods of Boston
which we all know everybody knows that
intuitively and yet the popular fantasy
of Campus rate as an rape as an epidemic
persists encouraged by regular
high-profile hoaxes in 2016 a female
student from this very State at Austin P
State University reported a sexual
assault she refused to provide a
description of the suspect she changed
her story she later admitted that she
made the whole thing up
that same year an undergraduate woman at
Clemson falsely claimed to have been
abducted and sexually assaulted the
following year a female undergraduate at
the College of Charleston accused her
classmate of sexual assault after a
night of drinking a jury took just 28
minutes to acquit the falsely accused
man the evidence was so overwhelming
that the woman had lied
but by that point the college had
already labeled the man a rapist and
thrown him out of school these hoaxes
are not without consequences that's why
it's so important to get to the truth of
these matters the truth that the
Liberals want to cover up that same year
a 21 year old Michigan student claimed
to have been raped by a stranger while
walking back to her car when police
investigated she refused a physical
examination she changed virtually every
detail of her account the story
unraveled when she finally named a
suspect that suspect presented
investigators with text messages from
the accuser in which the accuser had
accused another man at a different
location of committing the same rape
police later charged her with filing a
false report
and then there was rolling stone do you
remember the Rolling Stone story
I I have been paying a lot of attention
to Rolling Stone running fall stories
because they happened to do one against
me recently and so I I was already
skeptical of their journalism but they
really blew it back in 2014.
Rolling Stone alleged in a lengthy
article that members of the Phi Kappa
Psi Fraternity had gang raped an
undergraduate identified only as Jackie
as part of an initiation ritual
the thinly sourced story offered no
evidence for its shocking claims
the accuser's story as you may recall
fell apart and rolling stone retracted
the story in its entirety the following
year par for the course for Rolling
Stone and the liberal media and the
whole liberal establishment
when it comes to sexual hoaxes this is
not a new phenomenon either this is a
time-tested strategy that has served the
liberal agenda well for decades do you
remember the Duke lacrosse scandal
2006 a stripper named Crystal Gayle
Mangum alleged that members of the Duke
lacrosse team had raped her the
prosecutor Mike Nifong suppressed
evidence as the case fell apart and all
charges were dropped the following year
now
Nifong was later disbarred Mangum ended
up in prison for murdering her boyfriend
but
Justice came too late for the members of
the Duke lacrosse team whose education
and reputations were destroyed destroyed
for a lie specifically a lie designed to
advance a liberal political agenda